the sun is just rising above the crest
of the horizon on the major league
baseball season but there
there's hope
for days and for weeks and for months
and for a championship to get his
opening night 21 from angels stadium in
anaheim california the first of a 162
game journey we are ready to go may i
present to you dylan bundy the opening
day starter who last year in 11 starts
in 65 and two thirds innings struck out
72. tim anderson will step in
no fastball by him he's looking breaking
ball
it's a pretty good move a little
two-seam action for dylan bundy so one
up and one down good to have adam eaton
back in a white sox uniform as he'll
stand in the number two man rolls that
one on the ground to the right side
looks like he pulled the string two outs
that's soft contact split change jose
abreu the reigning mvp swings away and
he hits one on the ground into right for
a base hit
two out opposite field single
and that is the first hit of the year
for the white sox here comes johan
montana split finger change right over
the top of it and bundy has two
strikeouts lucas giolito who grew up not
too far from here will make his second
career opening day start guys here comes
a 2-2
and he swung through it strike three
that was the baffling changeup that
addles so many hitters that thing was
defying gravity here comes maybe
the most fascinating man in baseball
shohei ohtani he struck him out ohtani
off a changeup and lucas has the old
cabio working here in the first this is
what we live for right trout geolito
three and two on opening night it's a
great matchup it'll be a great matchup
all night he struck him out a changeup
that was just flat out dazzling he
strikes out fletcher ohtani and trout
three straight punchouts now for bundy
and it'll bring up luis robert robert
laces one in the left it's gonna get
down for a hit luis into second he'll
slide with a double
here's zach collins robert takes off for
third and he's safe he steals third a
little bit of a risk with two outs but
if they're going to give it to you take
it if they can throw that ball away you
could end up scoring a run because of it
this bounce away here he comes 88's
coming home and the sox have the first
run
of the 20-21 season and it comes because
of the speed of louise roberts six up
six down for roll number 27 so far
tonight lucas giolito and he'll face
jose iglesias owen two here
and iglesias does make contact which he
does so often but tim is on it and he
got him six and three one gone
max stassi the talented catcher three
two
called strike three painted the outside
corner on a heater five strikeouts for
giolito giolito serves swing and a miss
on a high changeup he's faced nine
batters he's got six strikeouts maurice
robert with monkatta at third grand all
at second and it was a good breaking
ball dexter fowler trickles over toward
that line gooby was on it folks
the good news is for angels fans
so was that man and so now we redo
geolito versus trout that's one of those
pitches there where pride intersects
with logic lucas didn't want to miss in
the zone and it's ball four there is
your first base run back to back walks
chance now justin upton do what he did
all spring training long produced runs
he's going to get a lot of these chances
this one lightning to center field upton
down for a base hit
proud hustling on around to the plate
for time back to back walks and now a
single by jaya continue what he did in
spring anderson chatting with pujols
down there at first base
eaton will check in for the third time
eaten to the pull side deep to right
field fowler is back at the wall it is
up it clangs back in and it is gone
bring him home for the first time
welcome back adam eaton
and it's 3-1 socks one away here in the
fifth max
stassi is the catcher
i fly ball center field robert goes back
to the wall
and that's the power for max stassie
entertaining us with a home run it's a
three to two game a rally brewing here
with the tying run now and scoring
position first and second for upton 2-2
there's a fastball down ripped to third
monkatta gets one and a double play
that'll get hoyer out of the inning and
here is jose abreu who won himself an
mvp award last year
hits it hard diving attempt to glaciers
up with it uses the dirt on across the
diamond in time
what a play by iglesias he continues to
amaze us with that defense
it's an error on madrigal and two on
nobody out for the angel and bummer now
has to face trout with two on and nobody
out in the eighth there are some planks
to be laid to get across this eighth
inning golf hot shot down the line
and we're tied
mike trout does it again and with the
big time reaction i love that with
trouty he's all about getting his team
to that next level what a job he did
here in the eighth inning ties it up and
the bases are loaded and the batter will
be albert pujols
bouncing ball hugs the line fielding
fire on across
albert pujols puts his team on top
iglesias goes to work he takes the rock
and he rolls the cuban native the 31
year old right hander switch hitting
laori garcia
there's the change up not strike three
that's a great sequence sells it well on
top that running action going down and
away if you make contact it's going to
be on the ground
wow oh my goodness three pitches good
morning good afternoon good night robert
and there was no need for a setup pitch
i love what iglesias did
goes right back said i'm going to go a
little further out i'm going to trust
max dassey to keep that in front collins
representing the last chance high fly
ball well struck right field dexter
fowler says i've got it
the angels are 1-0 to open up the
20-21 season boy what a game all the
small things to win a game max stassi
doing his job mike trout doing mike
trout thing feeding off the crowd ties
the game up with a single the angels
come back and win the game 4-3 against a
very good white sox team great pitching
throughout solid solid defense